hello everybody my name is markiplier
and get ready for the boss battle of our
lives kinda maybe a little bit I don't
know
cry not that intense but I'm gonna
destroy him anyway because that's who I
am
am I going anyway I thought wait a
minute where's the boss
oh that's right yeah okay no I'm dumb
that's right I went up the oh yeah okay
alright sorry I'm stupid um Oh dumb dumb
dumb dumb dumb dumb dumb dumb nice
relaxing elevator ride up to the top
nothing to worry about
where did he come from
yeah that didn't hurt at all
dumb such a badass let me just rub my
neck for a bit hey blue is one down
already 2 / 2 / ah you back you fed up
hey blue
hahahahahaha
and a brow you can't handle how that's
that kind of stung a bit come now I know
you did miss me dish and upper blah blah
gotcha
Oh dis far too proud to bra [ __ ] thing
what the hell just happened
I got like knocked to the side ah -
pearl your Abra gon still bro
gosh it'd be a death pay professional oh
wait
me Isaac Clark already an is dead space
professional duh so great ha ha all
right let's get in and meet back up with
Ellie ha ha ha Oh Ellie I miss your
boobs so much I miss them so much ok but
have we gone here this looks slightly
different than I remember
yep yeah this slightly - what Oh heavy
standard frame which way am I going
let's see what's up here I got time to
burn probably an artifact of some sort
scavenger BOTS waiting okay what is that
I got a pulse rifle no way you're
kidding me up oh there it is I almost
passed it right over oh that's a text
slug I thought that was an artifact
never mind oh there we go artifact
recovered da da da da what did I get
LOB's is traveling early in ninety day
it's always the same shambling another
storms trying to get in following orders
they're very warm and alive okay
whatever
until losers can't handle what they got
I'm actually kind of interested because
I I thought they took the pulse rifle
out I'm actually confused
is that what my is that what this gun
attachment is is that a pulse rifle I
don't know I have no idea
I think the pulse rifle is very unique
so I don't think that's quite it
anyway whoa hello yeah there's
definitely different from the demo they
like mashed a bunch of different levels
together from the demo which isn't bad I
mean I don't really care
I'm just saying that this is not the
same think super strong no no no yup yep
and hurry up there we go booyah in it to
win it
what's in here some diabolical hey
what's that oh it's a picture of someone
hello babies I only got eyes for Ellie's
boobs
I mean Ellie whoa no you stop it right
there where the [ __ ] do you come from
Holly balls Wow where they [ __ ]
coming from Jesus get off of me Jesus
Christ mom oh
full-auto
Jesus sake mi Noah
oh man give me a break
breath alright I sense a scavenge
location around here somewhere
Jesus Christ wait over there I thought
it was over here
you just told me I was over here stop
messing with me nobody messes with eyes
oh here right there
got it go find something little buddy
thank you have a nice day
yes surprise oh not pouch I guess I was
the only thing that was in here ray
upgrade circuit what do we got to clip
one damage not really that important to
me what is that oh it's like a body of
hazard suit or something I don't know
alright back on track what's that sound
I have no idea
alright whatever I need to find a bench
cuz I know I'm filling up on stuff I
need to drop it all off here pretty soon
thank you it's amazing in this new
fangled age they finally managed to
develop automatic doors no this looks
different
is this where they are about time
Isak you made that guy
I knew you'd catch up
good to see you made it Isaac maybe we
should give you two some time alone huh
what the hell does that mean it means
someone is in the past you're off the
glad to see him we need him this mission
needs what we need him are you need you
got something to say to me captain stop
just stop
we need to shut down that damn machine
and we don't even know where it is yet I
do I mean I think I know how to find it
what I've been digging through what's
left of the research notes and I thought
all that stuff was destroyed well
computer data yes but the written logs
discuss a signal tracking experiment
that pinpointed the machines exact
location well I think if we repeat it we
can do the same but it's at the other
end of the complex fine fine let's have
a look I could use a change of scenery
he's a real [ __ ] you know that
ah what a douche but I got admit I don't
blame him
let me just look at Isaac Clark chapter
10 man I'm like flying through this game
I think someone said there were like 17
chapters I believe I'm not exactly sure
so I'm already past halfway through the
game and I'm not gonna hit as many
optional things as before
I need a bench but seriously as if
Ellie's boobs would pick between him and
me
I mean Ellie yeah keep messing up there
as if Ellie would ever ever ha ha ha ha
that guy's got no chance and I know that
towards the end of the game he's gonna
end up betraying Isaac in some way so
whatevs
whatevs Bri real brat
rude okay so bench thank you ha finally
I've been dying for a bench yes yes yes
Gavin gee buck I love it on ya
and I know you guys told me about the
ration seals so I'm gonna I'm gonna look
into that let's see here
ultra weapon 30 ration shields epic
weapon or ultra weapon oh god I don't
have enough anyway oh oh I really want
it no show 2 for $50 $50 for okay
whatever this isn't a criticism this
isn't time to criticize on EA's price
couching I mean pricing whatever not my
call
I'm not gonna buy it so someone will
know wait
bank that's what I need got way too many
med packs which I never thought I'd say
I've got way too many med packs that
actually hasn't happened to me in the
past you know a few games I mean ever
since I got this gun I starts like
absolutely dominating everything that
comes my way making some pimp progress
wait for Isaac Isaac we just outside and
we're freezing hurry your ass up
whatever dick uh you know at first I
like I didn't like Carver although I
like Carver a lot more than the captain
this cuz Carver doesn't say anything
how he'll did an x-men find us come on
come on
run alley
okay yeah these guys don't even know
what the hell they're getting themselves
into at the moment so let's see huh boom
ha ha ha ha let's see oh now cover base
mechanics apparently come into play I
mean that's one thing that could have
been done without in dead space but you
gotta admit throughout the entire wall a
guy who's just like oh that was weird I
don't know if that was a ragdoll thing
or just part of the game the guy was
just like kneeling in the sand there but
I have anymore yes I do
scavenge me up I mean if you think about
it given its a full rich universe crazy
Unitologist there's got to be some guys
with guns trying to stop you from making
us old so in a way it does make sense
but still here that's impossible
not we shot space yeah well they did
Ellie can you make it to the warehouse
ah just take care of them
come on I'll be there soon baby I'll
have your boobs in my arms yeah I mean
dude you in my arms again
okay so I got separated obviously
because I couldn't be with my group for
two minutes no that couldn't be gotta
isolate me oh there I guess that was
them
they seem like they're in a bit of a
panic I'm just standing here being a
badass Oh Jim or Sammy's down here whoa
hello what what the hell was that
heads floating let's just shotgun these
guys who cares
Oh Thank You Necromorph E you're a great
help
Wow mm this yeah they just got to kneel
in the snow here whoa
nope roof hey it's your Necromorphs that
you guys love so much why are you
fighting them Bobby this is weird
ha I guess that's God that's got to be a
design thing it's kind of cool and kind
of interesting it away okay that orange
glow is nothing
let's go Ellie all right I think we're
safe
we are anything but safe thereafter
Isaac and we're getting caught in the
crossfire
look the well the signal tracking
experiments should be inside uh-huh
you're not worth this much trouble Clark
shut up I'm worth 10 times 10 but wha I
lost my connection you will auto content
you playing offline yeah I'm glad it's
not like some games where I have to be
connected to the internet for this to
work I mean if I was live-streaming yet
I'd be a problem but I'm not so ergo
good I am happy we're still going don't
know what happened to my internet but
you guys won't know about it cuz I'm not
livestream everything
hey sweet you guys take care of those
I'm gonna look for supplies or some good
job you failed
hahaha this isn't fun to watch oh hey
no thank you hey buddy how's it going Oh
double Cal you guys couldn't even kill
that Necromorph what is wrong with you
guys oh wow
these guys don't even know the first
thing about taking on Necromorphs bow
bow [ __ ] mother Foggia the inventory
full not again
you gotta be kidding me I just doll my
god I've got 10 kajillion Med backs
can't I sell them or scrap them or
something I'm gonna have a bank full of
med packs is redonkulous this is we're
dog
oh god okay uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh
God and I've got too much a no do you
believe that I've got too much ammo why
am i oh wait I can sell it I can sell
okay why didn't I notice this before
somatic gel I guess that's good
maybe scrap metal and not bad whoops no
cell transducers I need those sell those
off sell that off and just have some
spares here yeah I can sell them badass
yeah duh I'm Isaac Clark I don't have
boss scavenger BOTS of elbows I'm bench
ah I can't get away from the bench
Thank You scavenge II I will call you
Billy
I haven't called many things Billy in a
while so you're gonna be the first Billy
that I've called Billy in a long time
yeah okay moving forward
killing Necromorphs being awesome who
dr. okay am I gonna go yes I am in the
tunnel
no you're not I'm on him
hello does anybody else want to dance
I'm great at the tango and the Macarena
no one oh I don't blame you I'm kind of
a big deal see nothing nearby artifact
though oh yeah what did the artifacts do
by the way I have no idea are they just
like collectibles for Oh
oh yeah this is more of the demo - okay
I got it nerve but don't trust you Marco
has a plan
Hammond's heavy frame Hammond
that was the from the first dead space
they're gonna be ready
Bubba Pappy father pop pop boom pow pow
pow pow what how what done I actually
clipped out of
bah-bah-bah head floating oh that hurts
not ah - bro
no thank you do not get up please thank
you and bye thank you I mean go to hell
I mean whatever you Unitologist bleed
whatever whatever that place is go there
and burn in a fire wasn't there another
artifact over here or something maybe I
don't remember there being any artifacts
in the demo so I'm kind of just
wandering around well yeah this whole
stretch is pretty much all that the demo
was about
I remember the Hat
that's grody that's what that is adipose
no thank you no thank you
how about you not do that thank you
Jesus don't you things die you're just
floating heads God some of these things
like like I'm fine around normal video
game finals but some of the things are
this game just make my skin crawl
oh hello I remember you what da hell NEX
may be the way today stop the infection
was that they like made the planet go
into an ice age
what about you amateurs did that thing
to spontaneously Oh
tentacles
but I heard some by me ah damn it
it's the thingies No
stop that stop back creepy file what the
[ __ ] where the hell did you come from no
my shotgun is like way affect way too
effective it is so badass and I loved
every minute of it okay what we got here
another I got a box stuck on my hand
what oh no down no up and there we go
five thought something what's happening
Jesus go away alright let's try this
again with no interruptions
haha alright oh man like this this
messes with my brain a lot no how do i
Oh God
there we go that mess is like my brain
is not handling that very well at all
alright moving forward oh this is the
thingy ah ah now we get real boss battle
telemetry spiked rings I fall online
accession All Hands obstruction
please clear assumes really I love that
announcer if they put that announcer
voice on normal stuff you see in
everyday life it would make life so much
more epic like the navigator on maps is
like take a right in 500 feet or you die
that would make life so much better okay
anyway I need to find what did I get
like I want to see hang on I got to
modify this one because I need to do a
lot of stuff some about Hammonds
Hammonds heavy frame upper tool only
frame with built in upgrades okay let's
see Hammond had up Hammond had a pulse
rifle oh I got it I got a schematic for
a pulse rifle that's right that's what
happened for me maybe I could get like
some sort of explosive thing going on
here you know since I don't use my
secondary weapon all that much if I
could get ya an explosive canister
that'll work rocket launcher Oh
yeah states tatius support what can I
make Oh
what kind of it stretches come stay
Cisco acid bath Oh nah but I can't
afford to build all right I'll just go
standard oh that's so crazy that's
that's too crazy it's too crazy it's
messing with my mind I can't handle this
I can't handle this I can't handle this
hahaha oh man okay all right let's let's
give it a try
I'm like a kid in a toy store right now
this is just too amazing rocket launcher
hogwash yeah duh Isaac Clarke and I got
a rocket launcher what is that noise
a giant drill blocking my way out maybe
I can lower the safety gates way to find
out yeah this seems like a good idea
considering I've done this before
and it did not turn out well for me
kill me
confuse the sitter
haha
Wow back up boy thank you shotgun four
three two no not that not that not that
not [ __ ]
oh come on stereo
ah [ __ ] yo
cool holy balls
Salmonella typhi Nair resuming
operations in five four three two one
the other day oh you're not dead okay
will ya record Shannon kill that's a
that took me way longer last on stage
all systems shutting down yeah okay
Ellie we're headed to the warehouse now
is everything okay
oh yeah between this planet trying to
kill us
your boyfriend hating me this has been a
wonderful trip so far no usually like
this I don't know why just let us fight
it out okay one of us will win
eventually did you find the experiment
yes dad you'll just have to see it oh
good well one of us will have to fight
it out I think we know who would win in
a fight I stabbed a crazy person in the
eye or the head
it's crazy person stabbed Ellie in the
eye but did not mess with her boobs
gotta stop getting her boobs on my mind
hey Jesse what I'm doing is I'm mocking
the character's ID why would they scuzz
I remember dead space too like she
looked normal perfectly normal
like a normal human being and then
suddenly she gets a low-cut top and
gigantic boobs I found an artifact like
but you know ei tries to appeal things I
think she was I think she was a very
strong character before and what happens
also in this one they don't even give
her a weapon they turn it from a strong
character into the helpless of romantic
interest where two guys have to fight
against her and that's that's like
completely counterintuitive to what I
thought her character was which was a
badass who could survive of Necromorph
invasion the only one who survives of
her squad and the fact that she got
stabbed in the eye and then still went
like fought what's his name
ouch she hasn't fired anything what the
hell is this a yeah bull isn't it no
scientist called it the Nexus they
thought these bigger specimens that
acted as conduits
for the machines control signal
broadcasting into the smaller holes
why would that makes sense because I
think they call a machine like the
signal stuck the Silver Bridge is frozen
so how do we get it decided to use heat
exchanges let me try to nineteen don't
do it do not know click ok goggly a
furnace on the roof if I can find it I
can get it running again of course be
careful up there alright yeah don't hurt
yourself
haha shut up dick ha ha ha
that guy makes me laugh more than
anything just cuz he's kind of funny
yeah I don't know you still he's like
the stereotypical jealous boyfriend it
couldn't be more stereotypical but I
mean he's obviously gonna be jealous
because Isaac Clark is so frickin
awesome who wouldn't want to be Isaac
Clark's boyfriend girlfriend boyfriend
do boyfriend girlfriend dumber
personal luck hey is Serrano the Nexus
experiment is well it's incredible we
have discovered two nearly pristine
specimens and crews are working around
the clock to uncover them we're learning
so much about how these Necromorphs
communicated the whole species seems to
be connected by some telepathic signals
the holiest foot soldier to the
mightiest specimens but where is the
signal coming from I thought is what I
intend to find out I thought everyone
knew that it came from the marker
actually you know that's always confused
me about the marker because the marker
itself it causes the infection but at
the same time necro it repels
Necromorphs so I don't understand I
don't understand that I'm hoping some
questions are gonna be answered here new
suit available okay cool what did I do
to get that oh no anyway I am
unfortunately a yeah I am unfortunately
all out of time I'm sorry I'm having a
lot of fun playing this game i love this
game hope you guys are enjoying the
playthrough too so thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation for
more videos it I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
huh no no